[Music]
so everybody has their journal I'm
doggin I'm an alcoholic
name's Jerry can't be late track group
therapy is common enough in film and
television that many people's concept of
what it is probably comes from those
very group therapy scenes they're
watching yes would you like to maybe not
they are scenes that a writer can reach
for when they need to give a character
the opportunity to spill their guts but
they can be more than just a trope or an
easy excuse for emotional exposition
let's look at the anatomy of group
therapy and film and TV its uses and its
cliches this video is sponsored by movie
use the link in the description to get a
free 30-day trial there are a few
contexts in which this type of direct
emotional exposition from the character
would feel natural to the viewer where
else can you have your character openly
discuss the conflict they're dealing
with internally group therapy usually
requires the character to acknowledge
they have a problem from Drammen alcohol
which can be an important step to
advance our character and our story the
position of a group therapy seen in the
arc of the story often reveals a lot
about how it's being used
group therapy scenes early on in the
film are often used to set up a flawed
but coping character scenes in the later
half of the second act often come after
a character's darkest hour when they
have to accept they have a problem
group therapy scenes used this way bear
a similarity to scenes where a character
visits a church
Church scenes sometimes have the same
kind of emotional exposition we get from
a group therapy scene but in the form of
a confession or a conversation with a
priest I had a child husband started
running after than women but sometimes
they silently show the character is
simply ready to acknowledge some kind of
moral failing just say you're sorry for
what you did and you're sorry for who
you are and you're never gonna do it
again
these scenes can go beyond the
acknowledgment of a problem but you do
you do it again the therapy scenes can
involve the character acknowledging
implicitly or explicitly that they can't
solve their problems by themselves they
need help and they're no longer willing
to face their internal struggle on their
own and finally group therapy scenes
that come towards the end of the film in
the third act can show how our
protagonist has progressed and provides
some necessary emotional catharsis I'm
40 months clean I have a job at a rehab
it's fulfilling to help other people get
sober
moving from troubled to reformed from
addicted to independent from worthless
to worthy I believe art is functional
art as a tool writer Paul Schrader in
talking about his writing process
relates screenwriting to therapy what
you can use it to do learn about
yourself and learn about other people I
get 10 students and we have 10 problems
same thing creates stories that are
metaphors for personal struggles ok what
you're doing is group therapy and if a
story is built around personal struggle
it makes sense that writers might employ
the tools we use to overcome those
struggles in real life as tools for
narrative well why would you choose
group therapy over individual therapy or
a church scene story thrives on conflict
and a group setting provides the writer
with more opportunities to create
conflict for a character both internally
and externally ok please don't try and
commit suicide again experience few
people would go to individual therapy
and refuse to talk but the pressure to
step out and speak in front of others in
group therapy can add an additional
layer of drama for our character
sure yeah China
there's nothing on your mind Daisy you
want to tell us
we get to see the character find the
courage to open up for the first time my
name is Annie Hancock and I drink and
stuff
thanks for sharing thank you group
therapy also gives the writer the
opportunity to populate the group with
other relevant characters the director
can show their reactions creating
additional emotional drama something you
can't do with an individual therapy
scene the way a character interacts with
the group can reveal a lot about them
sorry I'm late
so get this I met with this retail
banker yesterday I'm supposed to be
getting to invest enough fund and
there's something about a circle of
people that lends itself to interesting
cinematography it can be a much-needed
break from simple setups that just
involve two or three people talking to
each other sometimes group therapy
scenes are motivated simply by the type
of story that's being told a deep enough
exploration of a character struggling
with addiction or mental health will
almost inevitably require a group
therapy scene I said I'm an alcoholic
I've been clean a few 24 hours now and
I'm still did certain that my disease
wants me dead
but some of the most interesting group
therapy scenes are those where the
emotional drama of the therapy is
secondary to the true conflict of the
scene in this scene from house of cards
we learn about Doug stampers alcoholism
and attitude towards life but the real
conflict comes from his speech being a
sort of veiled threat towards Peter or
so most people see fear as a weakness
they kept me sometimes for my job I have
to put fear in other people I know
that's not right but if I'm honest like
before step asks us to be I have to be
ruthless this scene from first reformed
inverts the usual dynamic of these
scenes and creates conflict for the
protagonist who's helping conduct the
therapy I think Cynthia what your father
is experiencing Christians shouldn't
succeed what he means
Christianity is for losers Jake okay
yeah I just get tired of turn the other
cheek and this scene from better call
Saul sets up what looks like a possible
emotional breakthrough for Mike it might
be painful but if you ask me I'd say
it's progress but he ends up taking out
his emotional energy on an imposter in
the room and the group as a whole
get her test results Mike you have
something you want to add you don't want
to hear what I have to say we're ready
if you are
yeah this guy was never married and his
disdain for the group tells us more
about his character than if he had
simply told the group and the audience
what he was struggling with emotionally
by now a group therapy scene may not be
the most original way to show the
audience a character's internal struggle
but tropes like this arise for a reason
these scenes are often an effective way
to naturally make an internal struggle
or external so if you're writing a group
therapy scene you just have to be aware
that you're covering very familiar
territory and so you should be extra
careful not to trip into the realm of
cliche this video was made in
collaboration with video essayist Hodges
you go check out his channel thanks to
MU B for sponsoring this video some
streaming services provide you with an
overwhelming selection that can make it
difficult to sort through what's good
and bad to find something new and
interesting to watch mu B is a cinema
streaming and download service that
solves this problem with a tightly
curated library mu B isn't just a
streaming service it's a place to find
great new film
watch I like that with every film they
include not just the film's synopsis but
an explanation of why the film was
picked by a movie you have 30 films to
choose from and every day you get access
to a new film try it out for free for 30
days by clicking the link in the
description and going to MU be calm /
Thomas flight that's mu VI calm / Thomas
flight thanks for watching thanks again
to hodges for helping me on this video
i've linked right here to one of my
favorite of his videos go watch it if
you're interested in supporting me on
patreon go to patreon.com/scishow this
flight among other things you'll get
access to a patreon Dischord where we
hang out and chat about film TV and more
I'll talk to you next time
[Music]